so it's been a lot of comments on some
of the other videos I've done about the
computers that exist in the background
of some of the shots and what they are
and why I've got them well they are
various models of the Atari ST family of
machines which after I'd finished with
the ZX Spectrum in the BBC microwave
from about 1990 onwards I grew up
playing around with and they were a
really nice machine to learn to program
on to do things with but also to do
general computing things and even play
the odd game so what we have here is the
initial setup that was originally
created in 1985 the machine was
developed over a period of about a year
from about the middle of 1984 after Jack
Tramel had bought Atari having left
commodore which he previously started he
taken with him shiraz ship G from
Commodore who's the creator of the
Commodore 64 and they set to work
producing a 16-bit machine a sort of
perhaps the success you might think the
Commodore 64
although the way it works internally was
quite different obviously if you look at
the interface on screen you can see that
it was also influenced by the Apple
Macintosh it had windows icons mice and
pointers so the machine itself is this
box here it's got the six eighty
thousand processor which is the same one
as in the Mac Plus over there it's got
the keyboard built-in and on these
connections for the mouse on the side
and also a joystick and you could take
them out and put a second joystick in if
you wanted came for the monitor this is
an Atari monitor although it's quite
common these machines certainly the
second revision could be plugged into a
television as well which is how most
people probably use them and at this
point they had an external floppy drive
what would you use if you didn't have
that footage olive oil hell no no so the
machine couldn't work without a floppy
drive so you had to buy the machine and
the floppy drive was a separate extra
until probably about 1987 when they
produced machines that looked a bit like
this which came in what was referred to
is the FT air for the SD FM although
this is a slightly later revision the
ste from about 1990 where they upgraded
the graphics and sound this machine had
a floppy drive built into the case as
well but they also made the mouse
joysticks ports access protected by
placing them underneath so you had to
pick the Machine up every time you
wanted to replace them bit of bad design
there I reckon so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to swap this machine over
for that one so you actually start
machine up run some software and just
see what it was like so
we've switched over to the more modern
machine with the floppy drive built in
as I said this is the enhanced version
the ste they did some extras with the
graphics but in general it's for all
intensive purposes similar to the
original machine one thing that's
obviously when you look at it is it was
inspired by the Macintosh the interface
is what's called gem it's developed by
digital research you've got your windows
icons mics and pointers so that a floppy
and proper aim with some software in
this case Mars 6 eight thousand
assembler and we can open up the floppy
and we get just like on the Macintosh
one immediate difference is that whereas
the Macintosh was black and white the
Atari ST had two color modes had a low
resolution color mode with 16 colors and
a slightly higher resolution mode with
four colors one of the things that
director Mel was trying to do you coined
the term power without the price in
order to give people a machine with the
same sort of power as the Macintosh in
fact it was actually slightly faster
than the original Macintosh with more
memory but at a much lower price and in
fact I think it's safe to say this was
the first computer on sale with a
megabyte of memory for less than $1000
when they brought out the one Meg
version but it's useful for various
things one of the things that people
often use this for was for playing games
you've got a variety of games hard disks
weren't that common on machines
particularly home machines and so you
had things on floppy disks and you would
have lots of properties so you get
little boxes like these to keep them in
the trouble I found with these things is
that these things were quite flimsy and
you drop them and they would shatter
into lots of pieces so the operators
Aamir was called toss stood for the
operating system although there was some
suggestions it might have been the
trommel operating system and it was
cobbled together from code written by
digital research for jam jam the
interface was also available for the PC
as well although it didn't take
because a small company in Seattle came
up with something that they called
Windows it was single tasking could run
one program at a time so when you
finished assembling something you would
stop that and change something else
perhaps to do some graphics or something
and then you go back to the assembler
and you end up swapping disks like crazy
to do that until you eventually gave in
and saved up enough money and bought a
hard disk so the operating system was
single tasking people did eventually
write multitasking ones as a chap in
Canada called Eric Smith who created
something called mint which stood for
mint is not toss until he got hired by
Atari and they started using it which
chemically cane mint is now toss and
that was extended into something called
multitasks which came out in the early
90s but there's also one produced by a
German called andreas chrome key called
magic which is what I tended to use back
in the 90s as I said one of the things
people used to use this a lot for was
playing games it's a popular home
computer and by the end of the by the
mid-90s the games have become quite
sophisticated this one I'm starting here
called substation is a sort of doom
clone and the graphics aren't quite as
textured as fantastic as you'd go on the
PC at the time but it's still a playable
game and still quite impressive for what
is an 8 megahertz processor with when
this case it's got 4 Meg what the game
would run with just one megabyte as
we've been talking the floppy just has
been going as it's loading the gaming
it's much slower and you saw how long it
took the games now loaded and we can
start playing and as I said it's a sort
of doom like game and we can sort of
explore this world the same thing and
there's no texture mapping but we've got
the same sort of exploring thing and the
monster just round here yeah I'm being
attacked by monster I I'm terrible at
these sort of games so when you finish
making you first let's play yeah because
I can hear sounds and everything as well
yeah so there's a to the mulleted volume
up there are sounds and things one of
the things I really liked about this
machine is a programmer in the 80s I'm
completely dead now is that these
machines were complex enough that you
could use them as
we use machines now I had word
processors test up publishers and so on
and use them for all sort of things up
until while I was at university I was
using these things I could log onto the
internet and connection browse the web
and things but they were still simple
enough that one person could understand
not just the software and how to write
programs but actually how the hardware
would work now the sound chip inside it
here it's not bad you can do some really
quite cool stuff with it but it wasn't
perhaps as the same with something like
the sid chip in the commodore 64 or the
sound chips in the amiga but what made
the difference with the Atari was what
was on the side on the side of the Atari
unlike pretty much all other machines at
the time were two MIDI ports musical
instrument digital interface so the MIDI
ports is a standard developed in the
synthesizer market for musical
instrument digital interface for
interconnecting musical instruments both
with each other but also with other
devices like computers and what this
meant was that musicians people like Fat
Boy slim soul2soul seal as well as
people writing schools for film and
television could use this machine and
edit their music recorded digitally not
the sound but the actual notes they were
playing into the computer and edit it on
the computer and then play it back and
the software that was developed on here
things like logic Cubase is still exist
today and people are still using them on
things like the Apple Mac and
occasionally a PC you could get add-ons
for other machines that provided MIDI
but one nice thing about the way it was
implemented on the Atari basically they
duplicated the way the keyboard worked
the keyboard that you type Tom as
opposed to a musical keyboard which
meant that the timing of the interrupts
and things that controlled the MIDI
ports was very very tight and so much
more reliable for handling music but I
think the story goes is that one of the
designers liked playing music or
something or some of them he knew liked
playing so they just added them on
because they could do it very very
easily it's almost as an afterthought
and yet it became the thing the machine
was perhaps most useful you often saw
them on Top of the Pops or other things
if you look on the extras on the Moulin
Rouge DVD even
probably six or seven years after the
machines popular at the heyday Fatboy
Slim's still there using it in the
background to create the music for a
major motion picture you only have this
small section that you can actually draw
into that was until the programmers came
along so they hacked it not so much that
they pushed it beyond what the designers
initially faced and for people who hated
computers this was wonderful it clearly
loves me